for
[Music]
I I read your comments and I just filmed
uh uh two of myi doing it different UK
different ukmi skills and both of the
nagas did the same thing which which is
totally fine um they're not shoving the
head down of the
UK and so you what I would say is watch
those two clips and notice how the UK's
head stays at the same distance from the
M
okay um that's the first thing to notice
so they're not the UK in other words is
not having their head shoved down and
then being told to bring their head up
that that's not what's happening what
happened is uh they did not take the
UK's head down and they worked with
where the head was at so the nag
adjusted for what the UK was
doing now granted in some of my versions
uh UK is taken outside of their uh base
of support that is possible by their
hands and their head does sometimes hit
the mat okay um and as I said the
pressure on that head is off much ear
earlier than bonai things okay so uh let
me have that that one okay so when I
come here the pressure is off already
that that's enough okay um so here is
where they all did it and this is fine
now the UK is not lifting their head up
but the UK
stopped themselves from putting their
head down
and that is upward energy okay so we'll
rewind the film a little when he goes
boom that's what I take forward that
energy I take forward not
here and then I say hey move forward
move forward there you go and then I go
that's not what happens
okay so the theuk has a choice that's
what I take forward the
the reput of their base of support
underneath their line of gravity is
upward energy and that's the upward
energy that I take forward okay um on on
some of my versions you see how I went
outside his hands okay um and then the
instinct is to do exactly what he did so
that hand wasn't
there wait yeah he's over here okay he
used his elbow that's upward energy so I
took that energy and I take it outside
that facee and now he put that hand down
that's the same upward energy and that's
what I take
forward
okay um
so in both cases if I'm looking at it in
the first case
they tactically
put them uh put the UK in a place where
they are able to put their base of
support back underneath and they will
the UK will and you're UK too okay
they'll put their hands
there but what you're not seeing is that
is upward energy that's the upward
energy that you take forward it's not
the head it's not that they get told to
lift their head or told to go forward or
or something like that it's only there
for a moment but you only need a moment
okay in my version I just fanned him out
more but structurally it's the same
exact thing and sometimes I do it
exactly like they did it okay um it's
still a matter of when they
post that is what you take up okay in
either
case I am off of the downward much
earlier than bonai is okay so what I
mean by that is bonai goes here you see
and now uh he he actually feels pinned
so why would he push up on it okay and
then you want to go hey try to get up
and then then you go like this you see
but what does bonai do as is they're
holding here he pins here and then you
go here like this okay so you're trying
to mix Styles but they they don't they
don't mix
okay so as I'm
going you can see I'm way
off of the downward of the downward
there's really no downward at all it's
more that 90°
modulation my hand is still on him just
because I'm keeping the connection I'm
keeping the connection he's not keeping
the connection okay so let's say then
that's what's happening
and he only goes to
here
okay his head is quite high but that
upward pressure of the post is what I
use to do this whole
movement
okay the problem that I'm
seeing is you are in the wrong place for
this what you have to do wherever you
wore so if I in my a lot of my
variations I'm over
here some variations here by Dy tend to
be here I've seen some people over here
whatever the variation is of where you
are as you neutralize this upper energy
with the 90°
modulation you have to move
yourself to where that's going to be so
here is his post let's let's rewind it
goes
boom and I move it I'm in the wrong
place I'm going to have to use my arm
here my
shoulder should have been
here you move
yourself where you need to
be if you can't move
them so if I'm here that's it that
worked that's the technique
he posted that's what I brought around
into my position to do the technique
he's not anywhere where I have to use
this hand because this hand cannot
function at the 90° modulations okay